have you been to any uh
brothels in europe oh man [ __ ] actually
yeah i have
nice in russia and so russian brothels
yeah it's lit what are those like
dude so check the story out so literally
after my fest this was um
like maybe like four years ago or three
years ago
i tell my uh the festival owner i want
to go to the best strip club in russia
and we're in moscow
cool see that i'm gonna take you we get
somewhere bro it's like bro like the
sketchiest
outside looking place i've ever seen in
my life but there's like 10 rolls royce
outside so i'm like oh [ __ ] like they're
like 10 double log outside sketchy you
walk inside but like just two big
russian guys like this padding you down
and there's an elevator but the elevator
you can only go up one by one oh weird
so i'm like okay cool so i'm with
two festival owners and two homies that
have yeah so i'm like okay one of you
festivals go first and i'll go after so
literally one by one going upstairs so
we go upstairs
and i was like yeah i want to go to
strip club but just a bunch of girls and
like martini dresses like and some weird
[ __ ]
and they're holding numbers on top of
their goddamn thing because they're
playing some game i don't [ __ ] know
it was really [ __ ] weird
but after everything they sit down
whorehouse
wow yeah wait so the girls weren't
holding the number so you could be like
i want number two they were no no they
were holding numbers because they were
playing some game with the dj but i
didn't understand the [ __ ] game
because i don't speak russian did it
feel like something like you know you
see these like action movies like triple
x or something and there's always like a
it's like does it feel like it's like
real sketchy like movie type [ __ ] oh no
the minute the minute we got ins the
outside looked sketchy but the minute we
got inside
lit not sketchy at all like everyone was
having fun it was all lit what did the
girl go for that you uh what was the
what was the going rate in russia
the going rate yeah
oh man what was it
i think like
two hundred bucks right here yeah like
250's 250. yeah 250 usd yeah usds wow
how many did you grab i just won just
one yeah was it was it was it worth the
250 dude yeah it's just bad we're still
friends you're friends with the russian
[ __ ] yeah nice when you say still
friends what's that mean oh like you
know it's actually right on the
instagram picture like oh hey how are
you doing like she's cool